si son comunistas operan o ateos
cayó en el orden oficial y en los testículos
años y la violencia Y la policía allí como
si sabes la verdad la corre
soy y como en eso por semana en marca
que efectivamente en los últimos 14 meses la
pasaron tres de ellos cuatro mas graves
en los cuatro operativos más graves
Los policías de Río de Lettali y los afectados no
justo
actores y el crimen organizado por
fundamentalmente también la población
civil en el que es un tema que miré
más problemas de gramática en materia
la política en Brasil y allí la política de
seguridad pública que las políticas fueron
adoptadas en este momento son parte de este
problema para identificar si lo que
cuando se trata de quedarse en uno
enfrentamiento entre grupos
los delincuentes y la policía con eficacia
abusos policiacos ser y querer uno
sistema de control que actualmente
esto esta totalmente neutralizado
infertilidad dentro de su país y dentro
de Río y los específicos entonces no
convierte todo en una guerra de
relacionar los signos que
no ha sido registrado y documentado por
más organizaciones de derechos humanos en el
país de guardia para la práctica del cabello
desproporcionada en fuerza por el
aquí a veces se pregunta a la policía frontal
usted es el que se presenta con
frecuencia que nos sirve
actualmente los estamos enfrentando
Espero que los votantes acudan a las autoridades.
los lugareños usan estos agentes
como una forma de promocionarte
personalmente y al tratar de engañar a algo
en los resultados de los votantes de
enfrentar discursos de actuación de un
noche su policía independientemente
por Emerson y si realmente observé
todo también se trata de zonas que
históricamente han sido olvidados y
parte de él ha estado en la situación que
bind es específicamente con un problema para
rezar a los sociales históricos que hacen
de éste uno de los países más de dos
Docente grupo global y también Rio de
demasiado en ese punto la comida es
que ser igual y no brasilero andré
Spector Jair bolsonaro y Su gobierno se
Aguja repetida de manera Condena en que
el tipo es operativo
sólo las referencias de condolencias a los
víctimas por la policía y el
familiar los días que nunca para que
el poder del habla es identificar
claramente si tocas el timbre para el
policía o cualquier otro tipo de
expresión de la palabra solidaridad
entre los pobres es mayoritariamente negro es
que viven en estas comunidades en estos
favelas en Marco De La Periferia
urbano de faze
adoptado en la medida plástica por lo que hay
estado allí la medida más importante para
descargar y cruzar contribuir a la disminución
de la violencia en las favelas que amarra el ácido
por los tuyos en estos operativos para que el
esta medida la Corte Suprema dio a entender
resultó en una disminución de la luz por la
mentalidades por reglamento
Actualmente las autoridades locales no
están cumpliendo con su decisión
su